Salut vous savez quel jour on est aujourd'hui ? Le jour de vous donner des nouvelles... de mon cul.
Vous êtes habitués maintenant, tous les deux mois je vais faire ma séance de laser pour faire retirer le tatouage que je me suis fait,
pour vous faire une petite vidéo et comme tous les deux mois je vous fais un vlog pour vous raconter comment ça s'est passé cette fois,
et puis pour vous dire surtout si ça a marché. Alors petit résumé des épisodes précédents, visuellement d'abord,
ça c'est le tatouage juste après la séance, c'est à dire tout frais tout propre ,
ça c'est le tatouage aujourd'hui, c'est à dire après la cinquième séance, qui aurait dû être l'avant dernière,
mais j'ai appris la dernière fois que finalement il faudrait au moins 10 séances au lieu de six, au moins 10.
Donc ça veut dire après un rapide calcul:
quatre séances supplémentaires, deux mois entre chaque séance, ça fait huit mois en plus, ça veut dire que je suis reparti pour pas loin d'un an !
Alors le truc marrant c'est que vous avez été hyper nombreux à m'envoyer des petits tips,
des conseils genre des vidéos que vous aviez vu sur des trucs super efficaces pour faire partir des tatouages comme le mien,
genre une machine dans une clinique à liège qui apparemment est hyper efficace,
y en a d'autres qui m'ont envoyé des pommades, d'autres qui m'ont envoyé des histoires d'injection...
J'avoue,
potentiellement, peut-être que je vais tenter des choses si vraiment la technique que je suis en train d'essayer actuellement marche pas du tout, mais pour l'instant
je préfère persévérer dans la voie que j'ai choisie au départ. Le truc marrant c'est que j'ai reçue aussi un message d'un médecin qui
me propose de me faire partir le tatouage au laser mais avec un laser a priori
différent de celui qui est utilisé en ce moment en 3 séances seulement
alors il me dit par contre je te préviens tu auras une petite trace cicatricielle alors
bon je vais recontacté pour en savoir un petit peu plus c'est à dire quel type de laser
est-ce qu'ils utilisent en quoi il est différent de celui que le médecin actuel utilise puis surtout qu'est ce qu'il entend par une petite trace
cicatriciel parce que bon ça beau être mes fesses c'est à dire un endroit qui
voit assez peu le jour j'ai quand même pas envie de me retrouver avec scarface scarfesse oooh
J'avais testé le laser un lendemain de cuite j'avais testé le laser pendant la canicule j'avais testé le laser en ayant très peu dormi
là je vais tester le laser
le matin et malade puisque ça fait une semaine peut-être que ça s'entend à ma voix que je me traîne une bonne vieille bronchite
des familles donc voilà petit petit piment supplémentaire petites expérimentations en plus
donc là je vais me coucher je vais manger avant vous inquiétez pas je peut-être même aller boire un p'tit coup on ne sait pas
je vais faire une bonne nuit de sommeil et on se retrouve demain matin pour la séance
Putain ça pique il est un peu tôt
Et c'est reparti
Prêt ? Allons-y
Voila. C'est bon ?
Mon produit de beauté ouais parce qu'en plus il faut se crémer les fesses
Ouais ça pique un peu quand on assoit
bon voilà ça s'est terminé alors première chose que je fais en rentrant général c'est de retirer le pansement parce que je suis un petit
peu allergique à tout ce qui est sparadrap adhésifs etc donc j'enlève le pansement
raison pour laquelle j'ai racheté de la pommade parce que comme ça j'en profite pour changer la bonne couche de pommades qu'il faut se remettre
tous les jours et même plusieurs fois par jour pour aider à la cicatrisation
du coup pas de pansements plus plein de pommade je vous laisse imaginer l'état de mes slips c'est un bonheur et donc le petit bilan
de la séance
alors d'abord fun fact je sais pas si je vous en avais déjà parlé mais le médecin
laseriste c'est le sosie de liam neeson et puis deuxième fun fact
il m'a dit quand je suis arrivé et que j'ai baissé mon slip hein parce que c'est ce qui se passe dans ces moments là
alors comment va le capitaine haddock
donc le mec est persuadé que je me suis tatoué le capitaine haddock sur le cul
il a augmenté un petit peu la puissance la dernière fois vous vous rappelez il avait augmenté la taille du faisceau là cette fois il
a gardé donc la même taille de faisceaux mais augmenter la puissance ça n'est pas encore flagrant 1
je vous montre à quoi ça ressemble immédiatement après la séance
c'est à dire juste après avoir enlevé mon pansement voilà ça ressemble à ça
c'est à dire que c'est assez gonflé tout autour de l'encre
mais que l'ancre on vois bien qu'elle n'a quand même pas encore éclaté en mille fragments donc cette fois encore c'était bien douloureux
je pense quand même que je commence à m'habituer parce que franchement
j'ai l'impression d'avoir eu moins mal que la dernière fois alors qu'il a augmenté la puissance de la machine
donc bon la bonne nouvelle la mauvaise nouvelle c'est qu'on a rediscuté du nombre de séances il m'a dit que effectivement
donc comme il l'avait dit la dernière fois on est plutôt sur dix et même
potentiellement sur encore plus que ça voilà bah on fait comme d'habitude là vous avez vu à quoi ça ressemblait juste avant
là je vous ai montré à quoi ça ressemblait juste après
demain et après demain je vous montrerai à quoi ça ressemble et puis on fera un petit bilan à la fin donc
aujourd'hui je vais vous laisser on en reparle on en reparle dans deux jours
donc ça c'est mes fesses juste après la séance de tatouage c'est à dire à quoi il ressemblait au tout début
ça c'est mon tatouage juste avant la séance de laser du jour
ça donc c'est le tatouage juste après la séance c'est à dire une fois que j'avais enlevé le pansement
là vous avez mes fesses et le tatouage qui va avec le lendemain de la séance de laser
et là c'est le tatouage deux jours après la séance de laser
et donc voilà à quoi ça ressemble à j + 2 c'est dingue hein c'est parti pratiquement complètement mais tout d'un coup quoi
non c'est faux c'est un prank évidemment ça n'est pas du tout partie plus que les fois précédentes donc
petit résumé j'ai repris rendez-vous pour dans deux mois pour la sixième séance qui aurait dû être la dernière
confirmation que donc il y en aura manifestement au minimum quatre de plus et même sans parler d'argent j'avoue que je commence à me dire
il n'y a pratiquement
aucun effet au bout de cinq séances est-ce que 5 de plus vraiment ça va faire partir complètement ce tatouage
je ne sais pas et puis il ya donc ce
brave ce brave laseriste qui m'a envoyé un message et qui me propose de me faire tout partir avec un laser différent en trois séances seulement mais
avec un petit des petites traces
cicatriciel donc j'ai depuis
échangé un peu avec lui il me dit que donc effectivement il y aurait des cicatrices
que je n'ai pas encore vu je vais lui demander des exemples
et qui seraient des cicatrices
définitive donc la question que je me pose et je vais vous demander de je vais vous mettre à contribution là dessus c'est
après la prochaine séance qui aurait dû être la dernière et qui manifestement sera pas du tout la dernière est-ce que
je continue la méthode actuelle c'est à dire je repars pour 4 de plus et on verra où est ce que je
tente la proposition de l'autre médecin c'est à dire un autre laser qui est censé tout me faire partir en trois séances
mais potentiellement avec des cicatrices donc évidemment
j'aurais la décision finale et ce sera notamment en fonction de la tronche des cicatrices que j'espère bien voir
d'ici là
mais j'ai quand même envie de vous demander votre avis et pour ça je vais vous donner rendez vous sur mon compte instagram vous allez
sur instagram vous tapez j m nl
voilà c'est comme mon compte twitter c'est jmnl @jmnl je ferai un petit
sondage dans ma story à l'heure où vous regardez cette vidéo d'ailleurs le sondage
sera déjà en ligne
je vous demanderai tout simplement de dire oui continue comme ça c'est à dire quatre séances de plus du même du même laser ou
non tente autre chose voilà en sachant que éventuellement si après ça ne marche toujours pas il reste encore d'autres
techniques mais on n'en est pas là voilà et bah écoutez dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo évidemment vous le savez mieux que tout le monde d'ici là qu'est ce que vous faites vous vous mettez bien surtout portez vous bien Ciao